ja ich ärgere mich über den moralischen
größenwahn in deutschlands
migrationspolitik es war im jahr 2015
sicher richtig in einer historischen
ausnahmesituation sogar unterbruch der
doping-regeln menschen in deutschland
aufzunehmen und ihnen zu helfen menschen
die nämlich zum damaligen zeitpunkt
festsaßen zum beispiel am bahnhof in
budapest das war eine humanitäre krise
da musste schnell gehandelt werden da
wurde gar nicht aber da ging es
eigentlich um menschen in einer
vergleichsweise geringe zahl nur was hat
deutschland gemacht man hat sich also
sehr gut gefallen unsere bundesregierung
in der rolle des moralischen
weltenretter ist hat das signal in die
welt gesendet graffities welcome und es
kam am ende hunderttausende indes kamen
hunderttausende
auch die eben gar keine asylgründe
hatten man hat nicht mehr unterschieden
zwischen tatsächlichen flüchtlingen und
migranten auf der suche nach einem
besseren leben und es ist ja völlig
legitim auch ein besseres leben
anzustreben aber dafür ist nicht unser
asylrecht gedacht das muss man einmal so
deutlich sagen und diese letztlich
verantwortungslose migrationspolitik hat
es jetzt dem weißrussischen diktator
lukaschenko doch sehr sehr leicht
gemacht migranten zu überzeugen dass sie
wenn er sie einst liegt
nach weißrussland dass er sie in marsch
setzen kann sozusagen und deutschland
sie sicherlich dann aufnehmen würde das
ist eine eine situation zu der die
deutsche bundespolitik die deutsche
bundesregierung leider beigetragen hat
so die polen unsere polnischen nachbarn
sichern jetzt diese außengrenze wozu sie
nach ihren statuten nach hinten
vertreten auch verpflichtet sind und was
mich so aufregt ist dass jetzt an dieser
stelle wo die polen sich einer sehr
schwierigen situation ausgesetzt sehen
jetzt aus deutschland immer noch diese
belehrung kommt also wenn ich höre jetzt
gerade von martin schulz der auch noch
ausgerechnet ein eigentlicher sogar
vergleichsweise basierter eu politiker
ist er in richtung polen jetzt sagt also
es geht ihm auf den zeiger dass polen
sich einer gemeinsamen migrationspolitik
verwehre da muss ich sagen die wahrheit
ist doch es gibt noch eine
vergleichsweise
gemeinsame linie in der eu und die
lautet qualifizierte zuwanderung und
auch schutz für tatsächlich schuber für
tatsächlich schützen könnte ja aber
illegale migration ist zu unterbinden
und dieser deutsche moralische
größenwahn des wir lassen jeden rein ist
zu einer gefährdung letztlich geworden
und hat beigetragen zu der situation wie
wir sie der außengrenze jetzt leider
sehen ist und entsetzliche bilder ist in
teilweise auch ärzte reißende bilder und
ich würde mir wünschen dass die deutsche
politik sich jetzt endlich auch mal
fragt was sie zu dieser bitteren lage
beigetragen hat mit den signalen die sie
in die welt geschickt
sebastian du weißt wie oft dieselbe
meinung in unserer zusammenarbeit hier
haben wir sie aber definitiv nicht ich
finde es furchtbar muss ich sagen in der
deutschen gesellschaft er ist immer mit
so einem jahr schon für mich ist es fast
schon so eine angst vor der fremde
dieses lädt deutschen sollen die grenzen
dicht machen wir deutschen sollten unter
uns wenn wir sollten die nicht
reinlassen soll das weiß ich aber viele
sagen ich finde das weiß meine
überhöhung aber ich sage moralischer
größenwahn moralische größe weil wenn
ich das sehe auch was jetzt bei diktator
lukaschenko passiert da kann ich nicht
die deutsche politik für verantwortlich
machen dass es einfach auch furchtbar
was da passiert und ich würde viel mehr
fordern er ist vielleicht auch jeder
einzelne überlegt wie er die integration
wir haben ja jetzt flüchtlinge hier also
wir können 1000 mal sagen wir haben
darauf keine lust die werden jetzt
erstmal bleiben ich finde vielleicht
kann jeder einzelne vielleicht sollten
wir eine integrationspolitik machen wo
wir auch an die menschen appellieren und
sagen was können sie denn vielleicht
auch tun ich habe zum beispiel letzten
zwei jahren zu wenig gemacht davor habe
ich was er für die integration von
flüchtlingen gemacht meine mutter
betreut zum beispiel flüchtlingsjungen
schon seit jahren und bringt ihm deutsch
waren solche was dabei sagen das macht
sie nicht irgendwie um samariterin sie
liebt dass sie gewinnt so viel
lebensfreude dadurch sie liebt das mit
diesem jungen deutsch beizubringen die
war an weihnachten damals sogar mittags
bei seiner familie ich finde diese
angstmacherei wäre doch viel schöner
wenn wir mal sagen vielleicht bin ich da
wirklich ein bisschen weltfremd auch
wenn wir mal sagen was kann jeder
einzelne tun sollte jetzt nicht lieber
die bundesregierung initiativen gründen
am anfang gab es viele unternehmer an
die initiative wird zusammen wo ist das
alles ich finde wir reden alle über
krone aber eigentlich wird auch gar
nicht mehr darüber geredet was können
wir tun damit es nicht mehr moralischer
größenwahn ist sondern dass diese
menschen integriert werden warum machen
wir nicht wieder eine willkommenskultur
das ist wirklich für mich ich denke wir
müssen da mehr tun und nicht weniger
nein ich sage wir müssen den richtigen
willkommen heißen das ist ja dass so das
heißt wenn man das während die richtigen
das ist das ist natürlich schwierig aber
eher eine ganz wichtige bedingung um
überhaupt eine steuerungsfähigkeit zu
haben ist die sicherung der außengrenzen
und es ist wirklich furchtbar was ich da
in diesen stunden gerettet und
vielleicht das hat das muss man
tatsächlich verhält das ist ja so dass
das da ist nichts schönzureden aber wenn
wir feststellen müssen dass wir zu
dieser situation beigetragen haben indem
wir signale in die welt geschickt haben
nämlich dass das menschen im zweifel
erst mal kommen können und wir im
zweifel erst mal jeden reinlassen und
wer dann hinterher schauen na ja wer ist
denn überhaupt tatsächlich dazu
berechtigt wären muss abgeschoben werden
bleibt aber faktisch fieber wir es gar
nicht bewältigen können auf die
abschiebung ich wäre ja sogar für so
etwas wie doppelten spurwechsel dass wir
sagen okay mut wäre jetzt da es ist da
lasst uns anschauen wie kann man
menschen integrieren es gibt ja viele
menschen es gibt ja auch tolle
erfolgsgeschichte tatsächlich es gibt ja
es gibt ja die sind mit 12 gekommen oder
sowie sprechen jetzt quasi muttersprache
nicht deutsch die machen abitur die
können diesen studien dass man bis jetzt
sicherheit für den diplomatischen dieses
problem zu lösen statt sich darüber so
aufzuregen bist ja schon mal ist ein
agent der diplomatie jetzt genau diese
frage anzugehen und nicht den einzelnen
mitgliedstaaten vorwürfe zumal ich würde
den vorwurf zu lassen zusagen im rahmen
der ratspräsidentschaft im jahr 2020
wurde versäumt im übrigen aus deutscher
sicht als die ratspräsidentschaft bei
uns war der gemeinsame idee zu
entwickeln finden für migrations- und
asylpolitik in unserem land an dem
vorwurf würde ich mich gerne festhalten
aber jetzt zu diesen stunden bei diesen
bildern die wir sie brauchen wir glaube
ich exakte diplomatie ja wir brauchen
auch eine rational gebracht und da bin
ich bei dir weil die grenzen die wir
sehen sind auch unsere grenzen die
grenzen die polen sichern sind auch
unsere grenzen weil wir sind schengen
raum und das sind unsere außengrenzen
und die müssten gesichert werden wir
können uns nicht einlassen auf ein spiel
das er gespielt wird was ja ein die
stabilisierung des spieles der
europäischen union auch deutschlands wo
gesagt wird kommentar alle zu uns mit
fliegern über dubai und sonst wär und
über die türkei genau das gleiche spiel
was man gemacht hat im übrigen mitte was
der was erdogan gemacht hat als er die
flüchtlinge griechenland geschickt hat
und die grenzen geöffnet hat das
passiert ja jetzt wieder und wir können
uns nicht dauerhaft darauf einlassen
deswegen muss man sagen so sehr man das
kritisieren kann was martin schulz ja
auch gemeint hat da mit der polnischen
politik aber die polen machen im grunde
im moment unseren job und sie machen ihn
so dass wir hier alle geschützt sind
denn die vorstellung dass von überall
her nun
unbegrenzt flüchtlinge kommen können in
die europäische union die irgendwann
nach deutschland kommen die ist
natürlich genauso falsch weil irgendwann
ist das maß auch die toleranz der
menschen auch die bereitschaft zu helfen
voll wenn es keinen geordneten weg gibt
dann können wir hier dann haben wir
andere afd ergebnisse als wir sie jetzt
schon haben und dann haben wir auch eine
andere politische stimmung die nicht
mehr hilft sondern die bereit ist hier
das als große konfrontation und
bedrohung zu sehen und deswegen brauche
ich hier europäische regelung und
regelung auch von der grenze es braucht
ein modernes einwanderungsgesetz was
auch so eine zuwanderung regelt und
unser asyl damit macht man sich nie
freunde aber unser asylrecht ist
natürlich unter anderen maßgaben
entwickelt worden das sollte denen
schutz bieten die wirklich vor allem
politisch verfolgt sind und meistens
auch aus europa haben so war der gedanke
damals vor dem hintergrund der
verbrechen die deutschland während des
dritten reiches verübt hat aber keiner
hat ja gedacht dass das so in dieser art
und weise ausgenutzt wird dass ihr
transit flieger über dubai bestiegen
werden ich lehne das nicht ab ich finde
ich sage nur wir müssen zum einen diese
politische erpressung unterbinden die
stattfindet wir zum anderen die
diplomatie anstrengen das sind für mich
die zwei punkte die wir machen müssen
und im inland ist und auch mit blick auf
europa brauche es in der tat eine gute
asyl und migrationspolitik und da
brauchst auch ein gutes zuwanderungs und
einwanderungsgesetz und das teil ich
aber ich halte die debatte für
vielschichtige europa wie sehen sie das
haben wir einen größten waren in der
flüchtlingspolitik in deutschland wie
gute frage nicht mein spezialgebiet aber
ich denke dann selber in indien geboren
da ausländische mutter ich glaube dass
man viel offener in der welt mit
nationalitäten umgehen muss ich verstehe
aber auch dass jedes land das sie bei
mailänder natürlich sorge hat von über
fremde über diesen punkt weil der kommt
ja immer in meinem vater kam auch aus
ungarn und das bringe ich auch gerne
einen toll dass er hier in deutschland
100 wurde auch verfolgt bis hierhin
gekommen hatte wenig und hat sich
jeweils auf gebäuden großartig aber
darum geht es das bringt er immer als
offene und tolerante menschen aber jetzt
darum geht es ja nicht hier sehen wir
menschen aus einem bestimmten zirkel von
ländern die meistens kommen das sind
afrikanische und länder des mittleren
und nahen ostens ich habe in afrika
gearbeitet als
student und ich glaube die ursachen
liegen im land wenn man dort lebt und
man hat angst um sein leben keine
wirtschaftliche perspektive hunger und
not und man sieht im fernsehen die
bilder aus deutschland und aus der
schönen welt wie sie hier glitzert und
funkelt dann ist doch klar dass man da
hin will wenn man perspektivlos ist und
ich denke es auch nicht neu das wird in
der politik auf seit jahrzehnten
diskutiert ist aber auch schwierig
umzusetzen vor ort